I thought this is the second time
they've done this this is sort of like a
gimmicky Christmas and July saying that
I I think a lot of people sort of rolled
their eyes at the first year they were
doing it but it was one of their busiest
days of the year last year busier than
Black Friday last year it helped bring
in a lot of Prime members these people
who pay ninety nine dollars a year it's
just a deal with they roll out a lot of
sales it's a way to sign up most
importantly though Prime members because
if they can get someone signed up for
their prime membership they're coming
after you sooner or later they've likely
got you for life and you're going to
spend a lot more on their site than you
do right now so amazon shares they fell
a little bit today people saying oh they
didn't tell that much but if that's not
really the point then does that really
matter me isn't the question sign ups
and one right how many people did they
sign up and will probably learn that and
when they release their next earnings
results but you know even though so we
got this data that looks at third party
people selling on the site that showed
it wasn't that much bigger than last
year but remember last year was still a
big year of sales and earlier in the day
they were having these glitches
technical glitches which could be a sign
either someone really messed up at
Amazon or that traffic was so heavy that
even Amazon this huge behemoth which
really sells the service to help people
handle huge web traffic was having
problems itself so it could actually end
up being being a boost for them but
we're going to have to wait till they
report their earnings another thing to
look at it how much do they have to lose
in margins which amazon it's not famous
for its margins so how much does they
have to lose in margins to offer these
deals to lure people then to sign up for
prime not famous for their margins but
they will a lot of people say they're
giving up the margins they're willing to
eat margins for today I heard they
signed up an extra thirty five percent
Prime members or they boosted their by
the course of last year by thirty five
percent last year yeah it amazes me
though we were talking about Amazon
compared to walmart and walmart does
almost 500 billion in annual sales
amazon only does a hundred billion and
change right so even though we think of
amazon is the biggest retailer in the
world right it still is dwarfed by wall
even Walmart's brick-and-mortar
operations alone in this whole world of
re in the total world of retail sales I
should also know that Walmart posts a
profit it was a horrible i'm doing
supposed to promise so Walmart's got
that on them too despite you know
amazon share performance which just
really has left walmart but in the world
of online retail so of course that's if
nothing is about where you are it's
where you're going and there's a sense
that we're all we're moving online more
and more online retail in the world of
online retail amazon has about seven
times the sales of walmart according to
our estimates so they do dwarf walmart
online and if you do believe that brick
and mortar is maybe not going away but
it's going to be marginalized and you
can see that a bit at walmart with
traffic to their stores slowing and them
struggling to grow sales in their stores
then you could say if you're looking at
the future long-term investing than
amazon's going to be a better play than
walmart if that's what you're looking at
so what is walmart doing to close that
online gap to compete with Amazon and
what kind of metrics did they use for
investors to look at we've got earning
season coming up what are they going to
be looking at to say are they closing
that gap yeah well a key thing that
investors are looking for online sales
which walmart does report in their
earnings and those have actually been
slowing so i mean here prime day for
example Walmart's offering free shipping
they're offering a lot of their own
discounts some of them looking better
than amazon's they've got their own
shipping pass programs is what Walmart's
doing a fraud Walmart's doing yet on
prime day yes and make a walmart Roger
walmart has they wouldn't call it prime
day per se but you know a bunch of deals
they coincidentally decided to launch
big from the same day on the same day
all week actually even even one-upping
amazon on that all week they've got
these deals going on free shipping
they've also got a service as trying to
compete with prime they you know did a
similar effort last year on Amazon's
prime day but so far there's no
indication Walmart's catching them
online sales growth is slowing at
Walmart Walmart knows as a problem
they've been investing billions